hi everyone is Jerry I just want to
review a game from the 2011 Chinese
chess championship it's a very brief
game but despite that it contains a
great deal of good characteristics in my
opinion it has a great deal of depth to
it it's very creative
there's unexpected moves involved we get
to see a queen sacrificing to top it all
off a nice finish one of those very
appealing windmill type of checkmate so
let's see exactly how White is able to
accomplish all of this in just 31 moves
so white opens up with d4 Knight f6 c4
e6 we quickly enter this nimzo-indian
defense indicated by this Bishop b4 move
and white gets right to the point
puts an immediate question to the bishop
and is okay with this current prong
structure now so these doubled pawns
tend to be the the one downside from
this but on the other hand again white
now has the bishop pair so moving
forward we have c5 which is very typical
a very typical way to approach this pawn
structure striking in the center
allowing the Queen to come out along
this diagonal and really just not
allowing this c4 or c3 pawn to now
advance so life continues with III
allows this Bishop LightSquared Bishop
to come out and now b6 allows this
bishop to you may think to come to this
long light square diagonal but in this
white pawn structure this Bishop will
often find it better to be placed on a6
where it puts pressure on the sensitive
points e4 so Bishop d3 taking aim at the
White Queen side or excuse me the black
King side or what's going to likely be
the black castled King side position you
might you know this is this is one
position here where you really can't
just go with these general rules of
thumb like Oh develop nights before the
bishops if you do do that okay Knight f3
well there's drawbacks with that sort of
move and I'll touch on that in a short
time from now so first we actually just
have Bishop d3 let's get this Bishop on
the diagonal we know it's going to
function best on
and now knight c6 and now Knight to e2
so the the night is gonna find it better
to be on e to in this sort of setup
because you do want to reserve the
option for this F pawn to advance as we
will see in this game it does happen so
Bishop a6 again focusing on this c4
point and now II for advancing in the
center allows this dark square Bishop to
come out black castles Bishop g5 this is
an annoying pin especially when black
does not have a dark square Bishop it's
difficult to cope with this this pin
that the knight is currently in and so
black goes about it in the following way
h6 kicks the bishop back to h4 and a g5
kicks it back to g3 so black did one
thing it got out of the pin but
unfortunately now there's serious
weaknesses in the the black position so
let's see exactly how white exploits
this d6 y d6 well the bishop is maybe
getting ready to go to d6 and be very
deep in the black position it would be a
very annoying piece to kind of get rid
of and it just really clogs up the black
position so that's what's prompting d6
by black and now f4 just creating pawn
exchanges trying to create more lines
more avenues towards the black King side
position and now Knight to a5 focusing
on this weak point c4 seems very logical
however white is able to come up with
some really really creative stuff so
capturing first on g5 we now have white
ignoring the pressure on this c4 pawn
and just castles instead really I mean
if you if you try to hang out to this
pawn after let's say I don't know maybe
maybe a move like Queen to e8
threatening threatening the Queen
exchange if the Queen's are exchanged in
this position I think it would start to
favor the black side because this this
really starts to become a liability and
with the Queen's off the board there's
really you really start to no longer
have
much more of an attack against the black
King or either King for that matter so
if we were to see Queen exchange at this
point the knight can recapture
conveniently guard d6 which the bishop
still has pressure on and now it seems
like this pawn is just going to be
falling so really you just kind of have
to abandon this idea of trying to hang
on to this c4 pawn and just go forth
with some sort of an attack against the
black King so white castles and now
Knight to h5 seems like a good move just
trying to eliminate this bishop and this
right here is one of those unexpected
type of moves Bishop takes d6 is this a
blunder or not actually when I first
just quickly reviewed this with the
computer the analysis showed up like
negative 1.8 which is indicating that
black is doing better but in just a few
more moves we start to see that the
tables turn and it's actually white
who's now the better side so it's hard
to you know blame black for maybe going
for this it's just white really came up
with some really really creative stuff
so let's see how white did it be 5 does
what hits the Queen allows the bishop to
come out and creates a pivot point for
this white rook on f6 Queen East 7 and
now Knight g3 what is this doing exactly
you may think it's okay we're just
getting ready to capture the knight but
its main purpose is just to clear have
this sort of clearance it's one of those
clearance type of moves it allows the
Queen to come out along this diagonal in
fact after Knight takes Knight the
knee-jerk reaction is to just capture
the knight but no white doesn't do that
rook f6 what does this move do exactly
well let's just see first what would
occur if we just do the routine
recapture type of move we now have to
cope with f5 and all of a sudden things
become that much more difficult to carry
on with because or it becomes more
difficult for white to attack I should
say because now the black Queen is able
to guard the seventh rank and this rook
can always bump itself up to f6 and do
similar
and in summary that the attack is that
much more difficult to again carry on
with but by not capturing the night
right away in first plane to f6 you
prevent black from advancing that pond
and there's still unfortunately no time
for this night to really save itself for
example if Knight f6 the Queen Jets out
to h5 and it's just downhill for black
at this point I mean what exactly to do
the knight can't move really I mean you
go to you go here it's gonna be mate so
the knight is really just stuck exactly
where it is the Queen's getting ready to
just take here with check etc and you
know after after Queen h5 if we just saw
this rook coming either bead or b8 or c8
just getting ready to just put their
running shoes on you know go to f8 e etc
we could just chop this Knight and you
know it's just really downhill I mean
after the recapture rook h6 and
unfortunately there's not going to be
any convenient defense at this point
maid is right around the corner starting
with the moves like rook h8 followed by
Queen to h6 so unfortunately what it's
coming down to is in this position after
rook f6 there's no time to really save
this night just kind of has to sit there
so in the meantime black recognizes this
plays King g7 allowing this rook to
contribute by way of h8 or g8 and now
Queen g4 getting ready for this matin to
capture followed by rook h6 so rook g8
allows a little flight Square for the
King on f8 and only now do we capture on
g3 so first we wanted to plug up the the
black position with this rook f6 move
and only then a few moves later do we go
ahead and capture on g3 so let's see how
black proceeds at this point Knight to
b7
clearly black is having to abandon this
plan of capturing on this c4 square if
if for example in this position the
bishop were to capture on c4 after move
like
Queen to h5 there's just too many too
many threats that white is has against
black at this point namely we have mate
coming around the corner at by the Queen
going to h6 and pressure additional
additional pressure is being placed on
this pawn on f7 so that's this this
right here is not going to work so what
black decides to do is reroute this
Knight to this d8 square to add a
defender to f7 so we have Knight b7
finally getting the last of white pieces
involved focusing their sights on f7 and
now Knight to d8 you'll note that while
the knight does one thing defends on f7
it it also its drawback I should say is
that there's now a disconnection between
the rooks this rook is now unprotected
and as is often the case in chess I've
said it before unprotected pieces leads
to tactics so makes sense to make a move
like Queen to e4 multiple things going
on what are the multiple things hits the
rook it allows the Queen to maybe come
to h7 so we have Queen - b7 as the the
reaction that black or black follows up
with Queen b7 and now after d5 and rook
to h8 we have a really really nice
finish if you'd like to pause the video
see if you can find the continuation for
white in this position okay
the follow up how the game proceeds at
this point is Queen to g6 giving check
and this Queen could just clearly be
captured by the pun but let me just show
one quick what if if King to f8
unfortunately black is in a position
where white at this point can really
just pick their favorite variation to go
ahead and win here's one of them just
take on e6 and before you know it pieces
are most certainly going to be crashing
through with this this lonely F pawn so
instead as occurred in the game the
Queen gets captured rook takes pawn
King to h7 check or King h7 is the only
move rook takes pawn discovered check
King h6 rook g6 check King aged seven
another another another discovered check
rook g4 King h6 rook f6 check King to h5
the only move and after rook to h4 black
ends up resigning because mate is coming
up and just one move if King g5 then we
have simply rook to g6 and that would be
mate just one other interesting
alternative that black could have had at
this point or excuse me
yeah the other alternative that black
could have had at this point coming up
is after rook g6 if the King were to
have played to let's say this h5 advance
there's a nice nice little finish that's
quite rare and that is to make this cute
little King to h2 move where there's no
defense against the following mate which
is to say both of these pawns will move
back to back and there's nothing that
black can do to prevent checkmate
for example if just let's say the Queen
captures on this square it doesn't
matter we advance our G pawns back to
back and this turns out to be checkmate
absolutely nothing that black can do
however in this particular game how it
ends up finishing is from this position
after rook to h4 black ends up resigning
so that's all for this video I hope you
got something out of it
take care bye